vous êtes la fille d'emile louis et je
dis c'est pas votre prénom or dans le
passé il vous est arrivé de paraître
sous votre véritable identité et même à
visage découvert pourquoi est ce que ce
n'est plus le cas pourquoi est ce que ce
n'est pas le cas ce soir sur le plateau
de balances ton post lorsque j'ai choisi
de vivre autrement dans un lieu tout à
fait différent et puis je veux préserver
ma famille c'est une décision qui date
de quand ya quelques années que j'ai
alors je vous ai présenté tout à l'heure
comme les autres invités comme fils ou
fille 2 mais c'est peut-être injuste
parce que en plus d'être là si d'emile
louis vous êtes la victime également
2000 oui je voudrais rectifier les
victimes sont d'abord celles qui sont
mortes mieux elles sont mortes et voyez
où on parle on t'a jamais d'elle
on parle toujours des tueurs qu'on
encense presque essais se sont d'abord
elles les victimes celles qui sont
mortes et celle qu'on connaîtra jamais
parce que l on a échappé
je sais pas la médiatisation ou bien
personne ne s'en est occupé non mais
vous avez entièrement raison vous
heureusement vous avait réchappé
d'agression aussi de votre père ce même
si vous voulez pas vous mettre au même
niveau vous êtes quand même une de ses
victimes
oui bien sûr en quoi consistaient ces
mauvais traitements si j'ose dire les
mauvais traitements étaient constants
fait tant sur le plan psychologique mais
tour l'ensemble de la fratrie
cette brimade notre mère si on est
beaucoup souffert vous étiez combien
pardon initialement nous étions 4
ensuite se sont greffés des enfants de
la dass parce que oui c'est à dire des
trois ce que ça a été plus loin que des
brimades un mot un peu d'amour un peu
faible que vous que vous utilisez ça a
été plus loin que ça n'est ce pas mais
des enfants de la moins que vous voulez
pas entrer dans les mines juste tous les
détails
ensuite on va parler des enfants la dass
mais non
j'ai pas trop envie de rentrer dans les
détails non mais je respecte ça tout à
fait alors je rebondis juste deux
secondes
ça veut dire que emile louis et votre
moment était famille d'accueil
oui d'ailleurs jacqueline fraysse l'une
des victimes dont on a retrouvé le
squelette et a été élevée chez nous
extravagant est ce que comme non c'est
pas extravagant lot 6 ses troupes
c'est tout ce qu'on veut c'est madame
est ce que comme dans dans le cas du
témoignage précédent vous avez été tout
aussi étonné ou un peu moins étonné dans
la mesure où vous avez vous vécu des
violences alors que dans le cas de cdg
dire du fils mais avec tous les
guillemets et qu'il faut de michel
fourniret
comme il était normal a priori il ne
pouvait pas se douter de quoi que ce
soit est ce que vous ça vous a estomaqué
ou zidi ou vous êtes dit c'est pas
étonnant c'est très étonnant très
différent vous doutiez quelque chose oui
depuis très jeune je savais que ce
n'était pas un être normal et vous aviez
chercher à en parler ou oui mais moi je
suis né il ya plus de 60 ans presque
soixante dix même donc parler de ces
choses-là
n'hésitez pas et le rôle de votre
mauvaise foi vous savez elle ne s'est
pas marié avec elle il lui par amour
elle s'est mariée parce qu'elle ya été
obligé harkis parce que lorsqu'elle l'a
rencontré elle avait à sa charge de ses
frères parce que ma grand-mère était
totalement défaillante le grand-père
également potentiel amicaux et la
majorité étant 21 ans maman n'aurait pas
pu garder son frère ses deux frères
d'accord je rebondis sur la question de
karl
je suis à fait abasourdi de de savoir
quand même que derrière le fait de
confier des enfants de la dass et quand
même des services
il ya quand même des des référents il ya
quand même des calmants des jeux jeux
complètent ces femmes et des hommes etc
heures de ces jeunes filles qui étaient
donc confier par la dass se sont
plaintes d'attouchements et je crois
qu'il a même été la première
condamnation
mais oui pour attentat à la pudeur donc
j'ajoute une chose il faut savoir que r
est un croyant il faudrait voir
actuellement la moyenne de deux visites
d'une famille d'accueil c'est tous les
26 ans le contrôle de 26 ans mais que
pour ça que dans notre manifeste au
monde que ce soit une fois par an et en
présence de réforme parce que bien
souvent si non seulement c'est tous les
26 ans mais l'enfant n'est pas là il
était la piscine il est alors on peut
pas voir s'il est en forme il ya
toujours une excuse ou les 26 ans déjà
il est plus enfants il n'est plus
enfants bien souvent malheureusement
l'avenir contre louis illustre tout à
fait ce dysfonctionnement sa première
constatation il n'était pas avec ma mère
il était avec une autre une autre
personne qui elle aussi avait en garde
des enfants confiés par la dass
d'ailleurs c'est bien durant une des
premières supposée victime 2008
puisqu'il ya eu un non lieu donc été
arrêtés confié cette personne mais la
question qui vient à l'esprit quand on
entend tout ce que vous dites de
tragique d'horrible est ce que dans
votre enfance
il y avait quand même à un moment un
autre des moments de bonheur qui relève
d'une enfance normale ou ce que votre
enfant ça a été intégralement ravagé le
seul moment de bonheur
c'était une amy lui mettez un point
d'honneur à ce que noël soit une fête
une vraie fête mais je pense que il
avait dû lui manquait probablement de ça
mais par contre il y avait quand même un
détail qui était assez troublant c'est
que lorsque nous recevions le le petit
père noël en chocolat en usage l'époque
qui vit toujours est il il mangeait la
tête de chaque père noël qu'est ce que
ça veut dire moi je ne suis pas
psychiatre mais bon est-ce que c'est un
symbole phallique est-ce que c'est
l'absence du père je ne sais pas où est
ce qu'il veut tuer le père mais à propos
de ce que vous dites il n'avait
peut-être pas connu ça est ce que vous
vous saviez à l'époque vous connaissiez
son passé lui aussi douloureux c'est un
enfant
as lui même il avait été certainement
abusé sexuellement il voudrait jamais
parlé non il n'a jamais parlé de ça
alors madame on a l'impression et là je
vais aussi des guillemets je ne connais
rien à la sphère que je vais pas
comparer non plus les deux cas que
michel fourniret deux sortes de
personnes normales mais quand même très
intelligente
excusez moi mais c'est un point de vue
extérieur et j'ai l'impression on
al'impression enfin que emile louis et
peut-être pas normal du tout et pas
intelligente non plus du tout est ce que
je me trompe ou est-ce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il est moins moins
structurés intellectuellement que michel
fourniret même si comparé est absurde
il est moins structurée mais il est
intelligent quand même il ya son
intelligence perverse monétisation
monsieur madame quand vous pas comme
comme disait céline tout à l'heure vous
parlez d'emile louis tu as fais pas de
votre père et est-ce que vous aussi
de la même façon que lui on a de la
chance aussi d'avoir votre témoignage et
c'est très très rare justement dallas
c'est une volonté effectivement de
dissocier le mot père de amy louis le
père ça se mérite
mais c'est un géniteur sans plus vous
savez ça peut être n'importe qui n'a que
l'ajout de partie où la maison 17 ans il
s'éteint
karim et gaspard qu'un homme ait cessé
c'est un peu comme avec régime
tout à l'heure vous disiez que vous
souhaitiez qu'on parle un peu plus des
victimes et moins de faits montre moi ce
soir j'ai envie qu'on parle si nous vous
ce que c'est ce que vous avez vécu vous
avez souffert vous avez subi deux que
vous êtes là devant nous est ce que vous
avez réussi madame a malgré tout à faire
votre vie ou offert votre vie je sais
pas comment on dit est ce que sait faire
est-ce que c'est refaire est-ce que là
aussi vous vous êtes apaisé est ce que
vous êtes suresnes est ce que vous vivez
avec forme de cauchemars qui reviennent
de temps en temps dans quel état
d'esprit on vit quand on est la fille
d'un monstre pareil alors tout d'abord
on poursuit sa vie on laisse dont la vie
autrement on fait en sorte que
de ne pas regarder derrière le problème
est que il ya quand même des cauchemars
récurrents et lorsque vous voyez une
petite scie comme comme estelle mouzin
parce que ça ne peut que vous
interpeller et et forcément je pense que
les cheminements ben voilà il est tout à
fait logique que j'ai repensé et on
parvient à être heureux apaisé à votre
place ou pas oui avec mon mari mes
enfants mes petits enfants maintenant ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure et
quart et demi a fait allusion à ce
moment était très fort sur le statut des
victimes
il ya un très beau ligne à quelques
années de ivan jablonka que sa fille qui
s'appelle laëtitia dans lequel il a
voulu rendre l'honneur à la victime est
ce qu'on parle tout le temps du mois
j'avais la victime et c'est ce que je
retiens un peu des deux témoignages
qu'on deux premiers témoignages qu'on
ait eu ce soir c'est que il faut c'est
très bien qu'on fasse cette émission on
apprend beaucoup de choses et vos
témoignages apportent mais peut-être
aussi un jour il faudrait qu'on puisse
rendre leur dignité à toutes ces
victimes qui on connaît le visage
estelle mouzin mais pas celles des
autres qui ne sont pas simplement des
numéros sur l'agenda d'un tueur en série
non seulement ils ne sont pas numéro
mais en plus en ce qui concerne les
jeunes filles qui ont été victimes des
lillois on en parle toujours comme d'une
entité mais on ne veut jamais dire il y
à jacqueline 10 parties enfin j'en passe
puisque nous sommes dans une émission et
c'est que c'est très long et c'est
dommage c'est dommage parce que ces
enfants là surtout celles la face et
enfants l'a été les adultes mais bon
elles ont vécu le pire toute leur vie
elles ont été placées dans des
circonstances plus ou moins bonnes
sereine et puis après la rencontre qu'il
celui qui va les appâter avec un tour de
manège qui va leur donner un petit peu
d'attention parce qu'elles recherchent
un père aussi et puis voilà c'est comme
ça qui va qui va laisser d'huîtres à les
séduire entre guillemets j'entends un et
qui va arriver à ses fins et des
appellations pardon
maintenant que l'ogre des ardennes le
boucher de saisie c'est pas des
expressions qui vous joueurs parce que
même si ces dénominations négative on a
l'impression que ça participe aussi de
leurs mythes une chance de glorification
paradoxal est-ce que vous permet à rien
si j'ai une question pour voiler ce que
vos enfants et vos petits seins comme
vous parle de votre père mes enfants ne
connaissent pas à ne le connaissent pas
le cas hier ils ne savent pas que tu
sais qui c'est d'accord sont battus ils
ne l'ont jamais connu non alors
brièvement n'ont même pas non alex il
est né un peu hâlé que vous avez le
sentiment que votre père agissait
toujours seul je n'en suis pas certaine
à et est ce que votre père tient un
point commun entre les deux affaires à
propos de la vérité n'a peut-être pas
établie ni les établit définitivement
mis dans un cas est ce que parlement me
louis pouvait être normal avoir de
l'humour et de temps en temps être un
quelqu'un de jeu mais me guy mais là
encore mais fréquentable enfin normal
l'humour débile luis je traduisais
souvent par des démocrite de l'un de
l'autre
une personne qui l'avait rencontré qu'il
trouvait disgracieuses ou peu évoluer à
son sens ni humiliations voilà c'est ça
mais il avait une amie sociale et aller
au café il avait des potes pas d'âme et
le copain ou pas papin pas d'amitié
durable non non 0 pendant que quel genre
de personne il fréquentait emile louis
les gens qui fréquentent l oms ne
trouvez pas intéressant mais mon seul
salon engage que moi mais c'était très
bref puisque il fréquentait quelqu'un
pendant 2 3 mois tous les jours
pratiquement ces gens qui inviter ou lui
aller chez eux mais c'est éphémère
vous avez le sentiment qu'il ne rendait
des services il rendait beaucoup de
services de quel ordre
c'était souvent à des dames qui était
soi disant malheureuse en amour avec
leur mari péter et que bizarrement plus
tard benz avait fait une tentative 10
c'est autre chose voyez je pense qu'il
devait faire comme avec beaucoup il est
drogué épuisé il abusé d'elle alix
pourquoi avoir accepté de témoigner
tout d'abord pour toutes ces victimes
fait bien parce que moi j'avais je
n'avais pas très envie de venir
depuis presque le début de votre
expression vous vous tenez à parler des
victimes en le sang est-ce que vous avez
un moment donné ressenti le besoin envie
de vous engager aussi pour ses enfants
de l'adase qui qui qui qui sont ceux qui
ont été des victimes d'emile louis en
l'occurrence mais pour d'autres est ce
que est ce que vous avez eu besoin
d'engagement c'est pas de cet ordre là
c'est pas de s'éteindre là pour la bonne
raison c'est que ces enfants-là requiert
une certaine attention une attention de
tous les instants et elle moi j'ai des
enfants je ne pourrais pas me consacrer
construit essentiellement à eux ou
essentiellement à mes enfants et ces
enfants là ce serait où mettre en péril
mais ma vie de famille ou bien ne pas
faire le travail correctement et pas les
accompagner correctement très bonnes
réponses
voilà et ça je ne pourrai pas le faire
dans la une réponse très honnête à
l'excédent
décidément il ya des points communs
entre les entre les dossiers un moment
il ya un détail qui rend la faire encore
plus terrible qu'elle ne peut l'être
vous ces camps pour réaliser que céline
quand vous avez été à pas pour l'un des
rapts et vous vous dites à un moment
vous avez été témoin d'un des meurtres
de votre père le meurtre d'une jeune
fille dans un bois vous avez assisté à
cela
j'étais très jeune oui c'est le décalage
je devais avoir 10 11 ans je crois ou
dit oui je n'avais pas fait ma communion
donc dont vous étiez en âge de
comprendre absolument ce qui se passait
comment se fait-il que vous ayez été sur
la scène de ce crime mes parents
travailler à des postes différents elles
matin à l'après midi donc
les jours de vacances ou de repos
hebdomadaire et 1000 nous regardaient
l'après midi ou le matin peu importe
et je me souviens qu'un soir nous avions
pris en charge une jeune femme dont je
n'ai pas vu le visage ça c'était à saint
florentin
elle avait un foulard sur la tête comme
ça se faisait dans les années 60 et donc
il nous a dit restez dans la voiture je
vais raccompagné je ne souvient pas du
nom je sais même pas s'il l'a dit et
mais fera pleurer ils sont plus jeunes
que moi donc je
pourtant je n'étais pas très courageuse
je suis descendu par un petit talus
parce que je ne trouvais pas de chemin
et je les trouvais voilà et vous avez dû
vivre avec ça le reste de votre vie
ce traumatisme un enfant dans pendant
quelques temps je me suis dit que
c'était pas réel et puis chose étonnant
c'est qu'il me louis qui ne faisait
jamais rien dans la maison c'était bien
chargé de mettre tout de suite ses
vêtements dans la machine à lire et il
m'a dit attention ce que tu as vu ta
mère peut subir le même sort pour un
enfant la mère oui oui les menaces tu as
posé pour un enfant c'est quelque chose
de terrible inimaginable imaginables on
enlève sa mère à qui j'étais à l'époque
très attaché voilà c'est dit que votre
autobiographie
une phrase qui m'a arrêté je la cite
j'ai écrit ce livre pour expliquer
comment un être humain parce que emile
louis mon père en est un qu'on le
veuille ou non
brises d'autres êtres humains il est
réduit en esclavage mental et moral
il n'y a pas de prédestination au
malheur il ya seulement des prédateurs
et des proies qu'est ce que vous vouliez
dire par cette phrase oui il ya des
prédateurs comme emile louis et puis les
trois c'est à dire les personnes qui lui
sont plus faibles
celle qu'il a pu réduire à l'état de
silence l'état de squelette pour
certains voilà c'est fait je suis très
émue excusez moi non madame je vous
comprends pas se laisser intimider par
les gens plus puissant que lui plus fort
est qu en face des gens qui avaient plus
d'allant il était comme un oui comme un
rien à côté une larve
oui c'est ça une vraie lavette oui y'a
pas d'autres termes je crois que c'était
ils auraient fait n'importe quoi pour
s'attirer les grâces de monsieur untel
de cliquer supposés être des personnes
extrêmement importante
alors qu'elle menait sa toute-puissance
exercée sur les gens très très faible on
va bien sûr aller que ce vous dites que
vous êtes là pour les victimes changé à
ma question qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de faire passer comme message pour
ses victimes
déjà qu'on ne les oublie jamais et puis
ensuite qu'on fasse en sorte qu'il y ait
plus d'enfants mais bon malheureusement
c'est utopique
je pense que des enfants maltraités
puisque ce sont des proies faciles
justement des petits êtres qui n'ont
rien demandé
malheureusement il y en aura tout le
temps c est ce que vous pensez qu on
fait ce qu'on peut pour qu'il n'y en ait
plus des petites victimes
lorsqu'on fait pas assez comment vous
jugez la société par rapport à ça de
temps en temps
alors heureusement que donc je
n'approuve pas tous les médias mais
heureusement qu'il y a des médias
parfois pour parler de certaines
affaires parce que soit en ce qui
concerne emile louis ya quand même eu
des faillites tous les niveaux de l'état
autant l'avouer c'est ce soit la dass
déjà les personnes qui avaient en charge
ces jeunes filles la dass
les instances judiciaires enfin de
cambon qu'est ce que c'est sont des
pauvres gamines qui ne sont pas
mentalement et des caisses quel enfer
être à la charge et la société voilà je
pense que c'est ce que malheureusement
bon nombre de personnes pensaient bon
débarras vous pensez qu'ils avaient un
mépris ça va du fait de leur condition
psychologique dont on sait qu'elles ont
été méprisés que c'est pour ça qu'on n'a
pas fait grand cas de leur situation
je pense oui il y avait un côté bon
débarras comme on donne un animal à
garder ensemble c'est vrai car il dit
que c est beaucoup fonctionnent pas quoi
ils étaient réels ne sont pas considérés
comme des sept possibles c'est ça alain
connes tournoi en l'état devrait mardi
investir davantage de ressources pour
les personnes les plus vulnérables et on
connaît pas leurs noms en fait c'est
pour ça que je sais très bien leur
montrer leur image c'est qu'on connaît
d'autres victimes qui la met l on les
connaît peu on connait alors vous avez
disparues de l'yonne c'était cette jeune
fille de la dass qui était en plus
handicapé mental est vraiment le plus
vulnérable ce sont des vies qui sont
déroulés intégralement dans la barbarie
là le malheur et la malédiction basse et
stationnement on se demande d'ailleurs
comment ça peut exister ce sont les
laissés pour contre dans mes seins sans
doute écarté du débat quand on voit
effectivement karl zéro qui qui qui
s'engagera avec ce manifeste nous dit
qu'un enfant sur 5 2 quai est victime de
pédocriminalité on peut imaginer que
quand on on concentre effectivement le
regard plus particulièrement sur des
enfants de la dass sur des enfants
je veux dire le taux doit être
certainement plus élevé parce qu'ils
sont pas encadrées parce que on fait
moins attention à eux deux c'est vrai
qu'on se dit cette société qui se dit
civilisé de queue qui par les droits de
l'homme qui décrètent des droits de
l'enfance qui estime que nous sommes
quand même meilleure que beaucoup
d'autres on a quand même beaucoup à
faire quoi surtout que karim on n'arrive
même pas terrible quoi rime sur le
schéma il ya un fléau la mécanique donc
qu'il faudrait koné honteux près une
raison sur les enfants les enfants ne
peuvent pas mettre de pression sur les
tailles peuvent pas manifester et le
jour ils peuvent descendre dans la rue
43e et d'autres d'autant plus que toutes
ces jeunes filles qui disparaissait été
classé comme fugueuse ce qui au bout
d'un moment devient extrêmement
improbable quand vous avez eu vent de
cette affaire et vous avez su que votre
père était le chauffeur de leur car qui
les qui les menait de leur domicile au
centre socio éducatif est ce que ça vous
a mis la puce à l'oreille à ce que vous
avant que ça se déclenche
vous avez pensé qu'ils avaient un
rapport alors moi je n'habitais plus sur
place d'accord donc maman m'a relaté
certains ferment disant oui il ya encore
une telle qui a disparu il ya la petite
machin qui habite là-bas qui a disparu
et jacqueline jacqueline qui habitait
chez nous quand même et je dis m'écoute
il ya quand même un problème c'est qu
emilie les toujours autour de tout ça ah
oui oui je sais je sais mais y'a des
frères ils font souffrir
ah oui donc elle savait à ce travail et
se doutait elle ajouté elle était dans
le déni mais elle savait bien sûr elle
se doutait pas parce que alex et vous ce
qu'il faut vraiment les gens rappeler je
me tourne vers 15 0 c'est que cette
affaire a été relancé par une émission
de télévision
les disparitions c'était une affaire en
territoire en un jour c'est président
s'adresse la jacques pradel pour
l'émission perdu de vue mais ça a tout
déclenché c'est un cas d'école
c'est incroyable et ce qui est fou c'est
que malgré ça la justice a traîné
pendant des années et des années et moi
le sentiment que j'ai en voyant en
renvoyant cette affaire c'est de me dire
que emile louis il a
il a la gueule d'un lampiste en fait
elle pour d'autres gens moi je crois pas
une seconde
c'est une conviction personnelle que
emile louis soit juste un serial killer
je pense qu'il a vraiment le profil bon
bain de par son job il est en contact
avec de la jeunesse et des filles
extrêmement facile à agresser
puisqu'elles sont handicapées mentales
et je pense que il n'a pas été le seul à
en profiter je suis désolé de dire ça
mais c'est ça me semblait certains
doutes qui persistent pour moi ni à
l'histoire il ya l'histoire très étrange
à lui du suicide du vrai faux suicide
louis jambes l argent rappel de quoi il
s'agit avait un gendarme qui avait fait
de cette affaire une affaire personnelle
la quête de sam c'était le dernier a pas
avoir abandonné
on sait jeune fille disparue et il est
mort dans un suicide qui avec un
objectif
ouais voilà l'adjectif qui convient le
mieux c'est bizarre puisqu'il est mort
suicidé de deux balles dans la tête
ce n'est pas évident ça arrive il faut
dire que techniquement il ya des cas il
ya une explication mais c'est quand même
extrêmement improbable
est ce que vous vous avez une conviction
sur le sur le sujet moi c'était aller
voir monsieur jambert le gendarme en
question donc mais qui était encore en
service à l'époque après la première
incarcération d huile oui concernant les
enfants qui étaient en garde chez sa
concubine
parce que lorsqu'il est sorti de prison
cette concubine n'a plus voulu
puisqu'elle n'avait plus de sources de
revenus les enfants lui ont quand même
été retiré
donc il est venu dormir chez ma mère ma
mère me téléphonent j'habite très loin
j'habite à 600 km donc mon mari et moi
nous sommes descendus et je lui dis dis
donc puisque tu dis que c'est un complot
contre toi tu fais attention il ya des
gens qui bougent la nuit sur les
graviers il s'est mis à rire comment
comme un homme s'il et puis il y avait
eu un fait divers locale le dit mais
qu'est ce qu'il est con celui là il a
avoué
non je savais que monsieur jean vais
recommencer à faire
recherche et puis moi je m'étais
beaucoup demander ce que pouvait devenir
jacqueline puisqu'elle était censé avoir
fugué
je suis quand même allé voir joubert est
bon il m'a envoyé voir un juge
d'instruction qui plier les cartons qui
s'est totalement moquer de moi il m'a
même pas regardé il m'a dit asseyez vous
dites moi ce que vous avez à dire quoi
parce que quand on est innocent comme le
prétendait mis lui même il ne leur en
garde à vue je pense que ça vous marque
on sait pas dire je m'en suis bien tiré
j'ai pris que 4 on non le 20 octobre
1900 en 2013 il est mort en prison oui
comment vous avez réagi soulagé ce sera
la dernière pour moi moi je suis soulagé
parce que je sais qu'il ne fera plus de
mal à personne j'ai eu un peu de
tristesse pour ma soeur parce que je
sais que quand c'est son père elle lève
c'est ton droit mais par contre moi je
ne lui pardonnerai jamais je ne
pardonnerai pas tant qu'on n'aura pas
retrouvé des victimes des supposées
victimes vivantes
il ya d'autres de ses enfants donc de
vos soeurs qui sont restés proches et
aimante sensible à son sort et à sa
situation
je crois que je sais pas si c'est ça
c'est qu'il ne faut pas déboulonner le
père il ne faut pas des vous donnez le
père et puis c'est la famille coûte que
coûte c'est la famille g désole la
famille au bout d'un certain temps
alix pour que l'information soit
complète donc emile louis un moment
avoué puis s'est rétracté il a été
condamné quand même
christine le disais il est mort il est
mort en prison est-ce que vous avez un
souvenir précis de la dernière fois que
vous l'avez vu la dernière conversation
que vous avez eue avec lui c'est une
politi c'était dans le
dans la salle de la cour d'assises donc
je les regardais ma mère avait pour la
petite anecdote sur la le temps ma mère
avait écrit un journal qui m'avait été
traitée par une les frères jusqu'au de
ma soeur je ne sais plus ce journal ma
soeur me dis il faut qu'on donne à la
police par la gendarmerie
maj en allemand ou c'est moi qui lui ai
dit non c'est moi qui lui dit il faut
qu'on le donne donc elle me l'a amené on
la donne aux gendarmes lors du procès
mon frère témoigner à la barre et mon
frère a dit que j'étais une odieuse
personne puisque j'avais remis ce
journal à la justice emilie lui ai dit
en me regardant c'est bien mon garçon
ces choses là ça se garde en famille
telle mobilisation
moi je suis je suis magistrat c'est un
coupable et géorgiens bon moi je n'avais
aucun doute mais qu'est ce qu'il y avait
dans ce journal des choses que l'on
avait subi quoi je je ne perdrai pas
forêt